brücke aus china die luftwaffe bringt
mehr als 100 deutsche aus dem corona
virus gebiet zurück sie müssen in
quarantäne
tag eins nach dem wrack cit
großbritannien hat die eben verlassen
mit feiern aber auch mit gemischten
gefühlen und heimsieg in garmisch thomas
dreesen rast bei der abfahrt allen davon
und gewinnt seinen zweiten wettkampf
dieser saison
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem ersten
februar an meiner seite ist für den
sport rudi cerne sehr gerne guten abend
die sorge vor dem corona virus bleibt
treibt blüten gesundheitsminister spahn
warnte vor panikmache und
verschwörungstheorien in den sozialen
netzwerken
es kehren gesunde menschen zu uns zurück
betonte er vor der landung der
ausgeflogenen deutschen die sind mit
ihren angehörigen inzwischen gut
angekommen mussten aber einen umweg
fliegen weil die bundeswehr maschine
nicht in moskau zwischen landen durfte
volker check mit 100 minuten verspätung
daheim die 128 rückkehrer aus china
haben frankfurt erreicht abgeschottet
von der öffentlichkeit zuerst der
medizinische check am airport dann zur
quarantäne in die kaserne
unter ihnen ist auch der deutsche
student jannik weiß er hat sich vor dem
abflug per handy video gemeldet die
südpfalz kasernen germersheim wird jetzt
ihr ersatz zuhause für 14 tage dann soll
sicher sein dass sich keiner mit dem
corona virus infiziert hat blitzblank
und vorbereitet auf die betreuung der
heimkehrer darunter zwei dutzend kinder
128 zimmer für je zwei personen 27
helfer vom roten kreuz gehen freiwillig
mit in die quarantäne haben sich zwei
wochen beim arbeitgeber befreien lassen
ehrensache als rotkreuz helfer sind wir
natürlich dafür da den menschen zu
helfen und wenn man dann hier in so
einer lage nicht sagen wir sind dabei
dann ist es glaube ich das falsche die
mitarbeiter und verantwortlichen kämpfen
hier auch gegen verschwörungstheorien
die besagen die heimkehrer bringen das
virus nach deutschland alles unter
kontrolle das soll auch der
presseauftritt von zwei ministern in
bonn signalisieren in bayern bei der
firma webasto war dass wir uns das erste
mal entdeckt worden jetzt sind
mitarbeiter und ihre familien panikmache
und mobbing ausgesetzt
wer auf einmal gesagt wird ihr dürft
nicht mehr einen kindergarten kommen sie
sich in der schule müssen die auf einmal
einzeln sitzen
wie sich werkstätten weigern die autos
zu reparieren
das china virus ist jetzt auch in
spanien angekommen quasi über
deutschland auf der kanaren insel la
gomera wird nämlich ein erkrankter
deutscher behandelt er soll engen
kontakt zu einem webasto mitarbeiter
gehabt haben
santina ist am flughafen in frankfurt
susanne wie wurden die menschen die
deutschen ausfuhren empfangen was
passiert jetzt mit ihnen am flughafen
jeden fall dass die ersten
untersuchungen und befragungen schon im
flieger stattfanden durch ärzte und
durch mitarbeiter des gesundheitsamtes
denn man wollte einfach schnell
herausfinden ob jemand symptome aufweist
um ihn dann so schnell wie möglich in
die uniklinik frankfurt einweisen zu
können
informationen darüber haben wir nicht
damit denke wir werden in kürze mehr
erfahren denn der hessische
gesundheitsminister hat die 19 uhr 30 zu
einer pk geladen alle anderen passagiere
sie werden zur stunde in medical
assessment center betreut das ist eine
medizinische einrichtung hier am
frankfurter flughafen die untersuchungen
dort werden so drei bis vier stunden
dauern und dann werden sie alle in
bussen nach germersheim gebracht wo sie
dann die nächsten 14 tage in kasernen in
quarantäne leben müssen kindern für
diese informationen aus frankfurt
susanne santina angesichts der
ausbreitung des corona virus hat die
chinesische regierung weitere drastische
maßnahmen verkündet paare werden
aufgefordert ihre hochzeiten zu
verschieben trauerfeiern für verstorbene
angehörige sollen klein gehalten werden
in der besonders betroffenen provinz
hubei wird die situation für die
menschen immer dramatischer viele
patienten werden abgewiesen es fehlt an
betten zwei klinik neubauten in haan
werden entlastung bringen eine davon
soll schon am montag patienten behandeln
die aktuellen entwicklungen zu dem virus
finden sie jederzeit auf heute.de dort
haben wir in einem schwerpunkt viele
hintergrundinformationen rund um das
thema zusammengestellt
tag eins nach dem backen
seit mitternacht ist großbritannien raus
aus der eu nach fast 50 gemeinsamen
jahren die flaggen in brüssel sind weg
es kommen verhandlungen über die
künftigen beziehungen die reaktionen
gemischt in berlin singen besorgte
briten die europahymne und am ärmelkanal
hissen engländer ein banner wie stola
view wir lieben die eu immer noch andere
triumphieren wir out wir sind haus aus
london andreas stammen ein countdown
eine kleine explosion eine große
erschütterung für europa auf dem platz
vom parlament feiern die praxis
befürworter dreieinhalb jahre drama der
sieg im referendum die verhandlung
schlacht in brüssel der aufstand des
parlaments vorbei großbritannien ist
raus
anlass gerecht englischer sektstadt
französischem champagner
das ist unser land es ist gut dass wir
wieder unabhängig sind wieder das steuer
über unser schicksal in den händen
halten gehen können wohin wir wollen
wir bekommen endlich wofür wir gestimmt
haben los geht's wir sind wieder ein
freies land hoffentlich kriegen wir das
hin
hierzu seien es ist vollbracht ich kann
gar nicht sagen wie fantastisch das ist
die offiziellen regierungsfähigkeit in
einem mini lichtshow am amtssitz des
premiers bigben vom band der glockenturm
außer betrieb wegen der restauration
nüchtern kein triumphgeheul boris
johnson weiß er regiert nun ein nicht eu
land worüber eine hälfte der briten
wütend und traurig ist es gibt natürlich
viele die sich sorgen machen einen
verlust spüren aber ich weiß wir werden
aus dieser chance einen überwältigenden
erfolg machen egal wie steinig der weg
vor uns auch sein mag elf monate lang
ändert sich praktisch nichts in dieser
übergangsphase müssen die künftigen
politischen und wirtschaftlichen
beziehungen mit der eu verhandelt werden
grau in grau
gemischte gefühle und die aussicht auf
mehr verhandlungs drama am tag eins nach
dem austritt
auf der anderen seite des kanals
bedauern aber auch warnungen sollten
verhandlungen über ein künftiges
handelsabkommen scheitern wäre
großbritannien nur irgend ein drittland
sagte eu-kommissionspräsident in von der
leyen
frankreichs präsident makro sprach von
einem schlag für europäer
es dürfe jetzt keinen schädlichen
wettbewerb zwischen den briten und der
eu geben und die bundeskanzlerin sagte
deutschland wolle ein enger partner und
freund des königreichs bleiben nach
washington
da kann sich us-präsident trump auf
einen freispruch im
amtsenthebungsverfahren einstellen denn
die demokraten sind mit ihrem versuch im
senat zeugen vorzuladen an jumps
republikanern gescheitert
es wäre ihre letzte chance gewesen mit
neuen zeugen und unterlagen zu belegen
das jump in der ukraine affäre seine
macht missbraucht und ermittlungen
behindert hat aus washington motivischen
gespanntes warten im plenum die
demokraten und einige republikaner
wollen kein überstürztes ende
diesem prozess dann ruft mitch mcconnell
der mehrheitsführer zur abstimmung
überzeugen
hinter den kulissen hat er einem deal
zugestimmt über schuld oder unschuld des
präsidenten wird erst am mittwoch
entschieden
und so stimmen auch einige
wackelkandidaten der republikaner gegen
die befragung von zeugen antrag
abgelehnt
nur zwei republikaner susan collins aus
maine und mitt romney aus utah stellten
sich gegen partei und präsident frust
fast food bei den demokraten
wenn der präsident freigesprochen wird
ohne zeugen ohne dokumente dann hat der
freispruch keinen wert weil die
amerikaner wissen dass dies kein echter
prozess war ohne zeugen ohne dokumente
eine tragödie sehr großen ausmaß danach
scheitern die demokraten noch viermal
mit abstimmungen über einzelne dass
immer neue vorwürfe aus dem buch von
john bolton den ex sicherheitsberater
trumps heraus sickern beeindruckt die
anhänger des präsidenten nicht selbst
wenn sein verhalten unangemessen war
erschüttert es nicht die grundfeste der
demokratie
und so dürfen alle senatoren hier ab
montag ihr urteil öffentlich begründen
dass sie dann am mittwoch über donald
trump fällen werden nachdem die mehrheit
der senatoren republikaner sind werden
sie aller voraussicht nach ihren
präsidenten frei sprechen immer tee
wissen in washington hat sich für die
demokraten dieser ganze aufwand gelohnt
ich glaube ja die demokraten sind
natürlich frustriert aber das ganze hier
kann ihnen auch im wahlkampf helfen
bonn entfernt wird zwar wahrscheinlich
der vermutlich politisch mächtigste
präsident der vereinigten staaten seit
langem sein weil sich eben die
republikaner im kongress auf gedeih und
verderb mit ihm verbunden haben weil sie
ihm einen blankoscheck geben aber das
macht vielen menschen draußen im land
auch ein stück weit angst das
mobilisiert wähler gegen schwamm
dazu kommt dass jeder zeuge natürlich
auch in den nächsten wochen wenn nicht
im senat dann eben in interviews
oder in büchern ihrer aussage machen
kann oder seine aussage machen kann und
obendrein ist es noch so dass einige
republikanische senatoren selber hier
sagen dass das verhalten des präsidenten
falsch war
es rechtfertige eben am ende nur keine
amtsenthebung aber daneben bitteschön
eine abwahl das könnten jedenfalls die
demokraten im wahlkampf sagen und das
könnte ihnen dann bei der wahl im
november am ende doch noch helfen die
einschätzung unseres usa korrespondenten
elmar theveßen vielen dank heftige
kritik hat eine entscheidung des
us-präsidenten zum einsatz von landminen
ausgelöst künftig darauf das us-militär
sogenannte anti personenminen verwenden
die sich nach angaben des weißen hauses
nach 30 tagen selbst zerstören
ein verbot würde für us-soldaten einen
schwerwiegenden nachteil bedeuten so die
begründung hilfsorganisationen warnen
aber vor der großen gefahr für
zivilisten
mehr als 160 staaten darunter
deutschland haben sich schon 1999 zum
verzicht auf solche waffen verpflichtet
eine weitere initiative des
us-präsidenten sorgte zu beginn der
woche für aufsehen sein nahost
friedensplan
die palästinenser lehnten ihn direkt am
dienstag ab jetzt kündigte
palästinenserpräsident abbas zudem an
alle beziehungen zu den usa und israel
abzubrechen auch die zusammenarbeit in
sicherheitsfragen werde eingestellt
sagte er bei einem treffen der
arabischen liga in kairo
der plan bevorzuge israel und werde
niemals von ihm akzeptiert nach
deutschland milliarden entlastungen für
die bürger fordert finanzminister scholz
der solidaritätszuschlag solle schon
mitte des jahres für die meisten
steuerzahler entfallen und nicht erst im
nächsten januar sagte er der neuen
osnabrücker zeitung
wegen der grossen überschüsse im
haushalt sei das möglich die fdp hat cdu
und csu aufgerufen dem spd vorschlag
zuzustimmen
was liegt an der küste und soll ab heute
freunde von kunst und kultur anlocken
europas kulturhauptstadt
zwei sind es in diesem jahr die eine
findet sich im westen von irland galway
belebt durch studenten und künstler eine
hochburg irischer musik mit manufakturen
der traditionellen instrumente die
andere stadt ist an der adria-küste in
kroatien rijeka von den feiern zur
eröffnung dort berichtet wolf christian
ulrich ein sternenregen von flex
arbeitern der industriehafen als große
bühne für eine rockoper so inszeniert
sich europas kulturhauptstadt rijeka in
wenigen minuten beginnt die große
eröffnungsshow den ganzen tag heute
schon happenings an jeder ecke nicht nur
der bürgermeister bester laune
immer mehr touristen entdecken rijeka
und ich glaube dass das
kulturhauptstadtjahr rica als
interessantes tourismusziel ins licht
rücken wird ein stück italien ein stück
habsburg ein stück balkan ein zeitstrahl
durch die gemütliche innenstadt erinnert
an die bewegte geschichte der stadt in
den vergangenen 120 jahren wurde rebecca
von sieben staaten beherrscht darunter
auch kurz nazi-deutschland hafen der
vielfalt lautet das motto für 2020 mehr
als 600 veranstaltungen sollen eine
million touristen anlocken
ich hoffe dass rebecca dass mein
kroatien und der bike an kulturell ein
bisschen an europa heran kommen
der tourismus soll auch in zukunft für
die bürger verträglich sein hören wir
die bar von ingo lang go ist seit zehn
jahren anlaufstelle für seinen kiez was
erwartet er vom kulturhauptstadtjahr
es ist gut dass den bürgern nach diesem
kulturhauptstadtjahr auch infrastruktur
bleiben wird dass sie viel aufgebaut und
renoviert wird
besucher werden über mediterrane märkte
flanieren viel kunst begegnen die
kaffeekultur würdigen und den abschied
von einer grossen industrie besichtigen
rijeka verspricht ein kulturjahr mit
herz
sie galt als königin der spannung mary
higgins clark eine der populärsten
schriftstellerinnen der gegenwart mit 92
ist die amerikanerin gestorben mit dem
schreiben begann die fünffache mutter
erst nach dem tod ihres mannes allein in
den usa verkaufte sie mehr als 100
millionen bücher bis ins hohe alter
lehrte sie ihre leser mit jährlich neuen
krimis das fürchten
einige davon wurden verfilmt zu ihren
bekanntesten werken zählen warte bis du
schläfst und schreie in der nacht und
einen jubelschrei dürfte heute thomas
riesen ausgestoßen haben mehrere nach
dem bravourstück thomas dreesen gewinnt
also das legendäre abfahrtsrennen auf
der kandahar piste in garmisch
partenkirchen
der 26-jährige rast mit startnummer 1
zum sieg und ist damit der erste
deutsche gewinner seit markus wasmeier
1992 thomas dreesen ballt die faust der
erste deutsche sieg auf der kandahar
seit 28 jahren in garmisch partenkirchen
gelingt ihm eine traumhafte abfahrt
nahezu ohne fehler mit der startnummer 1
rast thomas dreesen zur bestzeit
der norweger alexander olbort kinder ist
auch richtig schnell unterwegs doch ein
fehler im oberen strecken abschnitt
kostet in den sieg platz zwei dritter
wird der franzose johan clarey bei
thomas tresens ein triumph
dann aber wird der stehen einige
schnelle des virtuellen freunden aber
die stimmung war mega ist wahnsinn
joseph ferstl wird zwölfter andreas
sander landet auf rang 14
ja und in der fußball bundesliga setzt
sich die show des neuen dortmunder
angreifer sterling roland fords wieder
zwei tore beim 15 0 gegen union berlin
sieben treffer jetzt für den norweger in
drei spielen sieg auch für bayern
münchen 3 2 1 in mainz hoffenheim
schlägt leverkusen mit 2 zu 1 augsburg
bremen ebenfalls düsseldorf im ersten
spiel mit neu trainer uwe rösler nur
eins zu eins gegen frankfurt das
spitzenspiel leipzig gladbach läuft
gerade gestern der torlose vergleich von
hertha und schalke morgen noch
begegnungen in köln und paderborn
tabellenführer ist erstmals seit langem
wieder bayern münchen bleibt sich kann
theoretisch noch vorbeiziehen dortmund
im augenblick dritter vor gladbach
leverkusen und schalke frankfurt führt
die zweite tabellenhälfte an vor
wolfsburg und den hauptstadtclub mit
köln beginnt die region der sehr
gefährdeten mannschaften bremen auf dem
relegationsplatz düsseldorf dahinter und
ganz am ende paderborn friedhelm funkel
gerade als trainer des
tabellenvorletzten aus düsseldorf
entlassen ist dann gast im aktuellen
sportstudio heute abend von 23 uhr an
erster grand-slam-titel für sophia
kennen im finale der australian open
besiegt die 21 jahre alte
tennisspielerin aus den usa die
ehemalige weltranglisten-erste garbin
gurus aus spanien in drei sätzen
und wir haben noch erfolge im eiskanal
sowohl beim rodeln als auch im bob gab
es siege für deutsche im weltcup für den
rother johannes ludwig und das pop duo
noch nah weber johannes lochner bejubelt
seinen erfolg in st moritz dem mekka des
bobsports im zweier mit anschieber
christoph weber gelingt ihnen damit
erstmals in diesem winter ein sieg gegen
die bisher überragenden francesco
friedrich auch im kleinen schlitten da
flossen nun bei der wm starten
von platz 24 jahren die spitze dieses
kunststück verdankt johannes ludwig auch
den extremen wechselnden bedingungen in
oberhof
er gewinnt vor dem russen publishing co
und dem letzten tief lejnieks rekord
weltmeister felix loch wird fünfter
unerwartete siege sind doch die
schönsten und morgen von 10 uhr 15 an
wieder wintersport bei uns im zdf
wunderbar zum schluss noch der blick auf
einen acker in der nähe von würzburg der
plötzlich eine völlig neue bedeutung
bekommt durch den exit hat sich nämlich
auch der geografische mittelpunkt der eu
verschoben er bleibt in bayern wandert
aber etwa 70 kilometer weiter auf ein
feld in der gemeinde veitshöchheim um
mitternacht zogen einige bewohner
feierlich zu der stelle an der ein
denkmal steht das wetter morgen bekommt
kein denkmal der sonntag wird nämlich
regnerisch windig und mild die details
hat gleich katja hornuf claus kleber
freut sich auf sie um viertel vor elf im
heute schon einmal danke für ihr
interesse haben sie noch einen
fröhlichen samstagabend und bis morgen
wenn sie wirken auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren morgen ist mariä
lichtmess murmeltiertag und es ist fast
keine sonne zu sehen also würde auch
kein murmeltier seinen schatten bei uns
sehen können und das bedeutet ja laut
bauernregel dass es einen frühen
frühling gibt ja irgendwie ist der
frühling ja schon länger da und nur wenn
es nachts mal auf klar sinken die
temperaturen auf winterliche drei grad
starker bis stürmischer westwind treibt
regenwolken über norddeutschland die
regenschauer und gewitter im süden
verlassen uns in der nacht ostwärts aber
schon morgen beginnt es wieder zu regnen
am vormittag werden diese regenwolken
bereits die weser erreichen den
thüringer oberpfälzer und bayerischen
wald und nur in der küste sind sie kurz
die sonne
damit ist es dann nachmittags vorbei
dann erreichen die regenwolken nämlich
auch brandenburg und sachsen beim
starken bis stürmischen wind aus
westlichen bis südwestlichen richtungen
und es wird morgen noch mal sehr mild
mit temperaturen bis 16 grad
damit droht tauwetter in den alpen und
nicht nur das denn im allgäu können
innerhalb von 72 stunden also innerhalb
von drei tagen bis zu 100 liter regen
pro quadratmeter fallen
das bedeutet es drohen hochwasser und
überschwemmungen es wird also stürmisch
und regnerisch am montag danach kommt
der wetter und temperatursturz schönen
abend noch